For those of you who don't know
me, my name is Meghan Harris.
I am a data scientist at
Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer
Center.
And I'm here today
because I have a story
to tell you all about
data pipelines and R.
But before I get into that,
I do have a quick question
for all of you.
You don't have to
answer me out loud,
but when you see
this image, does it
make you feel anything or
have any ideas on what it is?
Well, this is my personal
100% accurate representation
of a data pipeline,
and now you're
all thinking I'm out
of my mind, and I
might be, but hear me out.
Of course, this isn't an
actual data pipeline, right?
But rather the mental
images and feelings
I had when I was tasked
with making a data
pipeline from scratch in my last
position as a data specialist.
The story I want to
tell you all today
is about how I
created that pipeline
in R within the
context of me being
a self-taught, programmer.
Those of us that
work in data, when
we think of data pipelines,
I sure as hell hope it
does not look like that.
But hopefully it looks maybe
something more like this.
A perfect data pipeline, clean
processes, clean structures,
great results.
This is a pipeline to most of
us, but in the last position
I was in, the pipeline looked
nothing like that at all.
If we could even say there was
a pipeline, it was very clunky.
No structure, no
automation, just bad vibes
and recklessness.
So, although I have learned a
lot and I have so much to share,
I don't have a lot
of time to talk.
Y'all we'll be lucky if
we get under 19 minutes,
I'm going to be honest.
So I pulled out four
main points that I
learned about creating
pipelines during this journey.
These are going to touch
on my first encounters
within the data and the
pipeline, the importance
of identifying the environmental
structures of the pipeline,
embedding validations
within the pipeline,
and understanding what
sustainability looks like
for the pipeline.
Now keep in mind that
all of these main points
could easily be their own
talks, their own lectures,
their own courses.
So I'll only touch on
the biggest takeaways.
However, I have created a list
of example pipeline scripts,
actual Shell template
documents that you guys can all
use that is in the repo
for this talk on GitHub.
Yes, I know.
Great right.
So with that out
of the way, I think
the best thing for me to do
is go back to the beginning
during those first encounters
I had with this pipeline.
And guys I know I'm
going to sound really
out of my mind again,
but the very first thing
I learned about making data
pipelines in R was to not open R.
Ah, now I know you're thinking
Megan we're at RStudio conf, what
are you talking about?
I know, but hear me out.
Let me give you some context.
This was me on my
first day as a data
specialist, my first
professional data position.
I am self-taught so
I'm already coming in.
Not familiar with
things, but I'm
also not familiar with
the subject matter.
This physician was
dealing with opioid data.
There was a lot of data
existing everywhere
and the organization I
was working directly with
did not have any
structure in place,
nor did they have
any expectations
about what I was to do.
So if I am a new self-taught
programmer newbie
and I'm coming in with no
direction, what did I do?
So just like this
dude is jumping head
first to get to the Winchester,
shout out to Shaun of the Dead.
I also dove in
headfirst into RStudio
as soon as I got any data,
and that's what I did.
Whenever I got a new
data set, I tried
to create R
programs immediately
and what I should have done was
actually started investigating.
I didn't ask basic questions.
I didn't ask for
code books, I didn't
try to validate anything.
It was just recklessness
and vibes, I told you guys.
But I argue this point
of not opening RStudio
with an example of
something that happens
to me that was traumatic.
I call it the Narcan story.
Now, for those of
you who don't know,
Narcan is a medication
that is used
to reverse opioid overdoses.
So, of course, working
with this type of data,
I'm going to see this
information at some point.
One day I get a data
set and there is
a variable in it called Narcan.
And like I did, opened up
RStudio, quickly, looked at it
and saw, oh, Narcan has
numbers in it, OK numbers.
So without doing anything
else, I immediately
start making automated
reports, dashboards.
I'm feeling like I am a
freakin' superwoman, man.
I'm awesome.
And, you know, I just I woke
up in the middle of the night,
like, months after that,
and I had just a random
just Eureka moment, kind of
felt like something was wrong.
I woke up and I was like, HMM,
something ain't right, chief.
What is it?
So I went to RStudio, I
opened it up and I saw a value
and it was 4 plus.
And guys, my heart sunk
because 4 plus is not a number.
4 plus is a string.
So four months I was
calculating off of this variable
that I did not even
know how, but I
was coercing a
character variable
into an numeric variable.
So imagine the
embarrassment of going back
after everyone's
relying on me for this
and being like, hey
guys, it's wrong.
So that was just one example of
many times that happened to me.
All right.
And clearly, you can see
here, I learned a lot,
but the main thing I learned
was to not jump into RStudio
as soon as you get a data set.
If you do want to
jump in it, only
use it to give you a
little bit of context,
a little bit of clues so that
you can ask more information.
It was a really
hard lesson that I
had to learn, to just go
through this iterative process
of asking questions,
but doing so
gave me just a little
bit more clarity.
So remember how that pipeline
looked like in my head
when I dove in headfirst
with no information?
Well, now that I had
an investigation,
it looks still messy.
It looks messy, and it
doesn't seem like much change.
But I guarantee you this
is a different picture.
But just enough
started to clear up.
So that I could accept
that fact that I needed
to start building on this.
I needed to make some structure.
So at this point,
we're going to try
to add some environmental
structure, right?
So the biggest thing I learned
about environmental structures
is that theta
pipelines can actually
exist in two types of
environments, something
that I'm terming as external
and internal environments.
Now, there's probably way
more sophisticated ways
to think about this
and break this down.
But I'm a beginner and
this is what my beginner
brain like made sense.
This is what made sense.
So when starting
out, I had realized
they had external things
outside of my computer
that was affecting the
data inside of my computer,
but also things inside of my
computer, inside of RStudio
that was affecting it as well.
And I'll explain both of them.
So when I say
external environment,
I'm talking about more
abstract concepts.
I'm talking about any kind of
data, interactions, decisions,
admin policies that can
affect the flow of the data.
Even the technology that's used
for data collection and even
the data literacy of whoever
you are working with.
It was so important to
identify all of these concepts
because at some
point, they are going
to affect your internal
flow of your pipeline.
It's going to affect how you end
up working with and structuring
your data internally.
Now, the internal
environment is what
most people think about when
they hear the words data
pipeline.
They think about the
actual file structures,
the flow of things
happening internally,
the logic of processing,
and even the data
security and storage methods.
Now, it should go
without saying that this
isn't the reality, right?
We don't have two
separate environments
that exist in silos.
There's external things that
affect internal things and vice
versa.
And this is a challenge
that most every data
person knows well.
Even if we don't think about
environments in this way,
I'm sure that if any of you
work in nonprofit or academia
or government or
anywhere, you probably
have some form of bureaucracy
affecting what you do,
maybe even conflicting
interests in decisions.
That's an example of this.
So what helps me
to better navigate
the interactions between
these two environments
was to repeatedly
tackle each environment
by introducing some structure,
some documentation for one,
and adjusting for the other.
So I just want to
give a really quick.
A sample of just
some documents that I
made to try to help
me out with this.
So when I was thinking
about structuring
my external
environment, you guys
got to remember I was
a one person data team.
Really, I was the only
person coding an R,
so everyone else that
I was working with
had no concept of this, did
not do any coding, whatever.
So my method of trying to
introduce some structure
was to get everybody
on the same page.
So for this example, I have
up here making metadata
and very loosely metadata is
literally just data about data.
What helped everybody else
around me to kind of help me
with what they wanted
was to make sure
that they understood
what was happening.
So what was the name of
the file like for the data?
How often was it collected?
How was it collected?
Those simple things
we don't think about,
it really helps to have
it documents it somewhere.
Another example, I
have is something
that I'm terming as
assess, attempt, repeat.
We all do this.
How many of you have gone
to a new organisation?
Saw the way that they were
doing something and was like,
HMM, this ain't right.
So you get in, you
assess your situation
and you attempt
to make a change.
Now, if we're lucky, it's
the attempt is successful
and it's great.
And what usually happens
is that we either
have people who have
been there that's
just like we're not doing that
or something just doesn't work.
So when I tried to
do this, I would
try to make the change outside
externally, maybe in a way
that we collect
data or anything.
But nine times out
of 10 I ended up
having to compromise and
make up for it internally
in my systems.
So speaking of
internally, there's
also some examples
of introducing
some structure this way.
So the first
example, I have here
is simply named "make
clean file structures".
And this is so much
more than like, oh,
making sure your
folder names are clean
and making sure your
data is in a data folder.
Your scripts are
in a script folder.
This also encompasses
knowing how
to work with R project files.
This encompasses
knowing where you
are in your working directory,
knowing knowledge about working
directories, because
that's the only way
that you are going to get
a full flow automation
process with everything
stored organized
in a good way and seamless.
And like I said, if you need to
more about working directories
or R project
files or anything,
Jenny Bryan and all
of the amazing people
have already made
resources for it,
especially with the here package
and that is linked on my repo.
I'm not going to act like
I know about that too much.
The next example,
I have is something
that I'm terming as
modlarizing your code.
Now, in this example,
it's being modularized
by data and component.
So this is a snip from
an actual large project
I had where I had so
many data sources, right?
So it made sense for me to do
the work for each data source
within one script.
Now, that's only
one way to do it.
You know, that's it might
work for you and it might not,
you know.
But another example
that you can also do
is modularizing your code
by function or by process.
And I usually do this when
I don't have too many data
sources and I have a
more manageable project.
Now in this example, I'm
showing three scripts
in my working directory here.
I have a docking
script, which I'll
explain that in the next slide.
I have a processing
script which is just
for doing transformations
and cleaning,
and I have a
visualization script
or this script for short,
which is literally just making
vizzes, right?
So what helped me
with these projects
was having individual
scripts that I
could call on when it was time
to use it in the pipeline.
So the last example, I
have here for structuring
internal environments
is something
that I'm calling connecting and
chaining where it makes sense.
And honestly, I could have
just called it docking scripts.
I don't know why
I talk too much.
So an example of
a docking script
is on these next
few slides, and I
want to stress the
importance of the content
in it is not so much important,
but just the logic of what
is happening is. Now, in my
terms in my Megan brain,
a docking script is one R
script that will literally
bring in your data, do your
cleaning, your validation,
do everything that
it needs to do.
So that when you hit that
source button at the top,
everything does
what it needs to do.
And your end result is
hopefully a deliverable
that you're looking for,
whether it is a Shiny
app or a clean data set.
So just to get into
it just a little bit,
the docking script starts
just like any other R script
will start. We'll
load in our libraries,
then the next
section will go into
is something that I
call the data process
check here.
Now this looks maybe
hopefully not complicated,
but this is literally
just bringing in your data
and then determining how you
want to have some logic values.
So if you want to do something
to check like very simply down
here, this last line, it's
just checking a new data
set against an old data set
to see if the value of rows
change.
And I don't
recommend doing that.
I don't have time to get
into why, but don't do it.
But you'll get a logic value
at the end of this section.
So then the next
section I have here
is a logic flow for processing.
So this is just very simple.
If scripts, if statements.
So if the data has updated,
we will then tell R to source
one of our modularized codes.
We will tell R that OK,
if there's new data,
go ahead and process that data.
If there's new data,
go ahead and make
a visualization for it.
So that can look very
complicated, obviously,
depending on what you got
going on in your project.
But after all of
that is done, you
can embed options in
your docking script
to render your output.
So in this case, it's a simple
HTML report and an example
of a working, hopefully working,
version of this is on the repo,
you can see.
So now that I've zoomed by that
and realize that, oh, I needed
environmental structure,
my data pipeline
looks like this in my head.
I still don't know what this is.
And I'm really anal, so
I hate that the lines are
crooked like that.
So what can I do to try to clear
up the image of my mental data
pipeline?
Well, we can add
data validations.
And let me tell you guys,
I am exposing myself
here because you
guys know what I
learned about data validations.
I learned that you
have to do them
because if you do
not check yourself,
you will indeed wreck yourself.
You absolutely will.
OK I'm going to be
honest, I am not
the person to stand up here
talking about validations.
I am still learning myself.
But I can tell you that the most
important thing that I learned
was to do them.
Because, man, I could
have saved myself so much
pain if I had just checked
that damn variable.
Man oh, my God.
So what I can do
is just give you
some examples of some
types of validations
that I did run into.
Now, I won't go into all
of these specifically.
This is kind of here
just for a think piece.
So if any of you
are doing the same,
you can reference,
this and be like, HMM,
do I have data that
fits this as well?
Now something that I did
actually learn on my own
is that validations can exist
externally and internally.
So in my case, or in my
opinion, the best scenario
has always been that validations
are implemented externally,
whether that's at the point of
data collection or whatever.
If it's external, if it's
externally implemented,
it might increase the chances
of your data being actually like
workable and clean by the time
it gets to you internally.
Hopefully it's less work,
but my usual scenario
has been that there's
no validation done
and that I have
to do everything.
And it feels like it's way
more work than it needs to be.
But that's just me, right?
So OK, I realized I
have to do validations.
That's the thing.
I did the manually
in R and there's
nothing wrong with that.
But it can be cumbersome.
But there's packages.
Guys, I didn't know this
shout out to Crystal Lewis
because she told me about
the pointblank package.
I was late, like I literally
learned about it two days ago.
I had to change my slides.
So this is here for both
of us to, or for all of us,
to learn together.
So if you are also in
the dark, like I was,
we can learn together because
I don't know about validations.
You just got to do them guys.
So, OK, now that
we have determined
that we needed data
validation, this
is what my pipeline looks like.
Now I see some shapes, but I'm
going to be honest with you
guys.
I still don't those lines,
so what else can I add?
So our last point
is sustainability.
So sustainability
can mean and look
like a lot of different things.
And I'm going to be honest guys,
because I was a one person data
team.
I did not have any
bandwidth to do any type
of real sustainability
efforts but what
I was able to do
was kind of look at the
work that I did to see, OK,
what is really going to
count for sustainability
or what's going to
help with this pipeline
and what do I wish
I could have done?
So this is just a
quick list of things
that I brainstormed
with, like, man,
like if I had the time
to do it, I wish I could.
But the things that I
did highlight and star
here are things that I
actually eventually did
get to do before I had
left that last position.
And my point of putting
this up here again
is a think piece slide.
So what I want all
of you to take away
from this part of the session
is to kind of ask yourself,
do you or your
organization, wherever
you're working with
your data, do you guys
have sustainability
efforts in place
or are you in a cyclic
cycle of just reaching
the next deadline?
And if so, are there ways
to start incorporating
making some sustainability
efforts to do some QA
or QI on your pipelines?
So the last thing I
can share with you
guys is just some really,
really quick examples
of things I tried to do
to try to document, right?
Because with me being
a one person data team,
the best thing I had to do
was documents everything
so that people that didn't
code or didn't do data
could understand what
needed to happen, especially
when I ended up resigning
so that my work didn't just
fall apart.
So this is an example that I
have fully on the repo as well,
and this is a data workflow map.
So what helped me was
actually visualizing
all the different
data sources that I
had going into one
of my pipelines,
literally explaining
where it was coming from,
but then visualizing
what's happening inside
of R for other people.
Another example,
I think this looks
really similar to a SQL schema.
I'm sorry I suck at
SQL, so I don't
know if that's true, but pretty
much again, just a readable
version so that people
that wasn't working in data
can look and say, OK,
we have these data sets
and these are the
variables in it.
And these are the
possible ways we
can relate them to one another.
OK so now that I've zoomed
by all of that, let's,
let's recap.
So this was my
pipeline in my head
before we did anything, when
we just jumped in headfirst.
This is what it looked
like when we started
to investigate that environment,
ask questions about the data.
This is what it looked like when
we added some structure, when
we realized data
validation was a thing
and when we tried to
add some sustainability.
And you know what?
I still don't know what
this is a picture of,
but I know that it
looks kind of pretty
and that it has some clear
shape, some straight lines
and some colors.
And maybe that's the point.
Right?
so if you are someone
that's just starting out
in data science or teaching
yourself how to use R like I was,
something that you
may have learned
is that having things just be
functional can be just enough.
And sometimes you may never even
know everything about the data
you're dealing with,
but you can appreciate
the beauty of the
unknowns and the efforts
that have been made to
create the pipeline that you
do have to work with.
Of course, through
time, you want
to evolve and use best
practices and feel
that we're 100%
knowledgeable on what we do.
But my hope is
that I've given you
guys something useful to
take back with you today
to try to make this
process of making
data pipelines a
little less painful,
especially if you're going to
do the same thing that I did
and make them from scratch.
in R, Thank you
for listening, guys.